The Joe Rogan experience. It's like a boxing, like turning with the punch.
Exactly. As that's all I got left, he said,
I'm going to turn my jaw as you punch it.
Yeah.
Some guys are masters at that stand right in front of dudes and let them throw
punches.
Well, it was really improved. God, Sammy doesn't need to see him like,
cause I was at the fight where Canelo Mayweather and like, are you,
do you remember that fight? Yeah. And just Mayweather just totally schooled him,
man. It was unbelievable.
Truly unbelievable to even just be there in that room and just watch,
there was so much confidence behind Canelo. Right.
And obviously like 80% of the crowd was Mexican. Right.
And you saw like 80% of crowds harshest broken because by the third round,
you know exactly what was going on. And it was just his complete domination.
And man, it was unbelievable to see.
Maybe where there's a real master. He's a modern.
Master to me. He's the greatest great of all time.
Meaning he's greater at boxing than like Stephen Hawking is at science.
In my opinion. There's a good argument for that because he's come close.
Here's the thing, like the sport is hit and not be hit.
Who does that better than Floyd Mayweather.
I can name three times in his career where he was hurt.
I can name them. Yeah. Zap, Judah, Shane. Right hook Shane Mosley, DeMarcus,
chop,
chop correlate to Margaret chapter up Corley almost like put them out and was
the same.
How about my Donna? My Donna.
Donna hit him at the end of the, yeah. At the end of the belly,
hit him in the right hand.
And Floyd didn't know where his corner was for a second. He was out of it.
But he's got a beard. That's the thing about Freud.
A lot of people don't realize that he's got the pretty boy,
but he could take a shot. And I remember just like, I'm like,
this guy is impossible to beat.
I think it's going to happen when he finds a Logan. Paul, how crazy is that?
Dude? I love him, dude. I like Logan.
Logan's a big kid.
It doesn't matter. It's like Canelo was big. They've all been big.
But you know what? Canelo the Floyd.
One of the things he did that was really intelligent.
He forced canal to go down to. I believe it was 150, one 54.
Pounds. Oh, did they have a catch weight? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
I think he did that because he knew Cornell had a hard time making one 54.
I mean now can I was at one 68. We fought 75 knocked out. Covelo.
I thought that was the one 68. No, that was the light. Yeah.
He knocked out COVID yeah. Great left hook. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But look at this.
I mean, that's obviously not real, but still Logan's got the size.
He's a big guy.
But it, it might be close.
And Floyd is tiny, but at the same time, it's like,
Logan's not going to hit Floyd with any shot that he hasn't been hit with
before.
The only way he could is if you got a bad referee and the referee lets them
tie up. So if the referee lets him let's Logan tie him up and
Logan can hit Floyd in the clinch. Right. Hurt him.
I don't think that.
Can you generate that much power? We flinch. You think low? You can. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Who's strong. Who can hit hard? Can you up from a clinch.
It happens all the time. Yeah.
But I don't need to see knocked out Steve Bay from the clinch.
Yeah.
Yeah. That was that short right hand. Yeah. Really nice. Yeah. I just,
I don't see anybody doing that to Floyd man.
Like if you watch the boys sparring stuff, do you ever watch his,
like the Mayweather gyms.
Amazing 15 minute rounds.
In the gym. He does not on his bicycle. In the gym.
He's in front of you talking. As you miss every single shot you throw at them.
And it's like, there's no way that Logan connects.
What I think could happen is that the fight is boring because
maybe Floyd can't inflict enough,
like one punch damage on Logan. So maybe it's boring.
And then maybe he wins in like the people's eyes. Cause it's like,
you actually went 10 rounds with Floyd, Mayweather this at the other.
If Floyd hurts and what,
what Floyd does is wears them out and it makes him fight stiff and uncomfortable
because he's been shot.
He's not going to be nearly as efficient. Yeah.
Logan is going to be much less efficient.
He's going to be trying really hard and he's never done.
I don't know how many rounds are doing, how many rounds are they doing?
Know eight maybe or something like that. I don't even know if they've announced,
but it's.
If I, if I was Floyd, I'd want it to be 12. Yeah. The longer the drag,
that guy into deep water and then beat the out of him because Floyd can do 12
rounds in his sleep. You can wake him up in the middle of the night. Yeah.
So like, if they were the same size, it wouldn't even be interesting.
And even the Logan's way bigger than him, it's still only mildly interesting.
Yeah.
Because you literally have the greatest boxer of all time versus a kid who's
like really athletic and really tough who can fight, but it's, you know,
he's not in that league. It's not, no, there's no, no discussion.
It's not a person on earth that thinks he's in the same league boxing.
But Floyd is, he's a true master, master a master. Yeah.
The greatest ever in my opinion, yes, I would.
I would say he's in the running like you sugar Ray Robinson.
Well, we just don't know a hundred and something and Oh,
but you would not want a wives for this. Like that's my dad's favorite boxer.
And like my dad's a huge boxing fan. He used to like cover boxing for the news.
He would go to Ali's camp. Like he has footage of Lake himself,
like shadow boxing with Ali. Yeah. It's unbelievable. And like,
if anybody's a boxing, no, no, no. He was, he worked for NBC. Really? Yeah.
He was like a newscaster. Yeah. And like he just, uh, yeah,
he did his wild stories. Like Forrest Gump.
He liked did like the first ever story on like hip hop music.
Like it was kind of crazy stuff, but like he, uh,
he has a video like shadow boxing with Muhammad Ali and the Muhammad Ali stops
and goes, uh, what do you box oranges?
Okay.
Well he's the biggest Ali fan in the world. And he saw, you know, sugar,
Ray Robinson,
I guess when he was a kid and he was like sugar Ray Robinson outside of like
him. And I'll leave. Those are the best I've ever seen.
But that's like a generational thing. Obviously.
Most boxers like to point to sugar.
Ray Robinson is the greatest of all time guys who are in the know of boxing.
He was a, he was also, but he was a different kind of master.
He would slugged it out with people. He would get in there if he had to. Yeah.
He fought rough and tumble. But here's my argument against that.
He lost to Jake. Lamata in a decision.
I can't imagine a world where Floyd Mayweather loses to Jake Lamata if they're
the same size,
I can't imagine a world where Floyd doesn't outbox him because Floyd has this.
He has a more intelligent approach and his,
his approaches to frustrate the out of you and,
and take angles on you and pop you. And then,
and then not let you hit them back. And then you get into fifth, sixth,
seventh round. He started going, Oh my God, this is how this fight is going.
I have to get desperate. Like I can't even hit this guy. I dare you to get done.
Then you start getting down the line and then he catches you.
Like he caught Ricky Hatton. That's beautiful. Yeah. Yep.
I mean, he's just like watching him just as like a boxing fan,
like watching him take away people's confidence.
Like I've watched him take Shane Mosley's confidence from him, like shame.
It did end up catching him with that, that, that right hand right hand. And uh,
but what happened was when Shane, I think through his like first or second jab,
Floyd had already timed him.
He threw the first chap and the Floyd came right over the top.
He has that like amazing kind of like slip.
And he comes right at the top of the right hand and he stunned Shane.
And then right after that, Shane was like, I can't even chat.
There's nothing I can do. This guy is on a different level.
And then he ended up catching him with that ripe, but still like, yeah,
he's just, he's just a great, I don't know what happened. I mean,
I want Logan to get the money.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.